tuve una charla con el gurú de los
ejercicios benítez mientras exploramos
este módulo de desviación estándar vemos
que aquí hay 18 puntos de color naranja
en esta historia y vemos que el promedio
de la muestra o la media de la muestra
es aproximadamente menos punto 2 ven me
comentaba que estos puntos naranja son
muestras de alguna distribución se
tienen estos puntos de aquí y este
módulo que él hizo calcula
automáticamente la media de la muestra
la cual es la tendencia central de estos
puntos al menos se estima la media de la
población que estamos muestreando
también calcula la desviación estándar
esta de aquí la cual es una forma de
medir el promedio de qué tan lejos están
estos puntos de la media de la muestra
bien comentaba que el propósito de este
módulo es dar una noción gráfica y
visual de qué es esto de las
desviaciones tantas que significa tener
una desviación estándar de 2.3 y cómo se
comportan muchas personas comprenden
rápidamente
concepto al usar este módulo tenemos un
impacto más grande si movemos algún
punto que esté lejos y lo acercamos si
juntamos más los puntos la desviación
estándar se vuelve más pequeña entre más
los juntos vemos que se vuelve más
estrecha la desviación estándar
y en cambio sí los voy alejando de la
media de la muestra la división estándar
se va a ser más grande como podemos ver
aquí lo que tenemos como desviación
estándar no es exactamente un promedio
sigo alejando los puntitos naranja y
vemos que nuestra desviación estándar se
hace más grande todavía y bueno ahorita
voy a juntar estos puntitos acercarlos a
la media de la muestra y vemos que se
hace más pequeña la desviación estándar
bueno dejemos de jugar y vamos a ver el
problema arregla a los 18 puntos
anaranjados de la muestra en este
programa para que la desviación estándar
de la muestra sea aproximadamente 2 y
bueno después de haber jugado con esto
me quedo que la desviación estándar de
esta muestra es aproximadamente de 1.9 y
vamos a mover esto para que se ajuste a
este número y aquí no vamos a tener una
solución única pueden haber varias
soluciones a esto y justo ahora acabo de
encontrar una de ellas algo que también
me indicó ven es que además de comprobar
nuestra respuesta que en este caso fue
correcta me comentó que podríamos checar
esto de mostrar las pistas
le doy clic aquí y me dice la desviación
estándar es más pequeña si los puntos
éstos naranja están más cerca de la
media
trate de mover un punto más cerca o más
lejos de la media de la muestra para ver
cómo la desviación estándar de la
muestra es afectada y es lo que vemos
mientras más alejo las muestras nuestros
puntos de la media de la muestra mi
desviación estándar va a aumentar se va
a ser más grande y en cambio sí los voy
acercando estos puntitos los voy
acercando a esta media de la muestra mi
desviación estándar se va a ser más
pequeña y también me dijo que
volviéramos a dar clic aquí
existen muchas formas de acomodar los
puntos de manera que la desviación
estándar de la muestra sea 2 vamos a ver
un ejemplo este es uno de ellos le
vuelvo a dar clic y ahora me da otra
distribución conforme le voy dando clic
aquí veo que de cierta manera los
resultados son diferentes pero todos
tienen algo en común
como por ejemplo cómo se agrupan los
puntos cerca de la media de la muestra
algo que quisiera aclarar es el que ven
haya incluido en este módulo este dibujo
de curva de campana con esta área
sombreada y lo hizo para mostrar un
estimado de cómo podría lucir la
distribución real con base en la
información que tenemos de estas
muestras nuestros puntitos naranja si la
media de la muestra es acertada y si en
verdad calcula la media real de esta
población
entonces se verá indicada en la zona
sombreada de en medio también suponemos
que tenemos una distribución de curva de
campana normal y este dibujo muestra
cómo luciría esta distribución con base
en la información